are you guys doing good now you're doing
I'm good are you wearing sunscreen no
I'm gonna uh you might pay the price
you're like me a little bit
I am we're one in the same yeah I think
you think you're effed but you know so
first I'm gonna start with
congratulations on Universal putting
this amazing matte painting behind you
yeah it really does actually um so I
love this movie it's so well done and
the one thing I took away from it is
that I do not have what it takes to be
an astronaut I no way could I do this
honestly do you think either of you have
what it takes to do what you portrayed
in the film no I don't have it I mean I
would I would love to go I think I have
certain elements like I would do it if
someone just put me in the spaceship
I'll go because I would love to do that
but the amount of work that went in I
mean oh my gosh these people they
sacrificed everything everything and
they were as committed as I think anyone
to anything in in history you know so it
was uh I think these people are pretty
incredible yeah absolutely yeah uh it's
hard I don't know that one could say
that about themselves
I would certainly I would certainly give
it a shot
I mean a time I'm gonna say maybe you
feel the third day the third day third
days third days little bit like son your
son test a sunburn test you and me were
cut there we don't know please don't
even make those guys are red get them
out of here right make it in the room
yeah look at me like out yeah no way
daywalker get out um but the thing uh
another thing that took away from this
is just how much everyone was willing to
sacrifice to make this mission happen
and the the you know it's unbelievable
the true story for you guys when you're
researching this thing these are one or
two things that has really stuck with
you in terms of oh my god I can't
believe they did this they definitely I
mean
yeah I read Michael Collins's book it's
called carrying the fire and it just
goes through step by step by step by
step what it took to get there from
being a test pilot all the way into the
program and becoming an astronaut and
there is one thing after another that
would just be nearly impossible in the
amount of studying the amount of
training I mean these guys were dropped
off in jungles and deserts for what for
a week just to survive just in case like
the you know the command module happened
to land in some weird place so they
understood how to survive I mean there's
just the amount of work that it took is
incomprehensible really yeah it was like
the the physics of orbital mechanics was
crazy to me that was like the one thing
where I was like are you kidding I had
no idea that sounds impossible like
getting two spacecraft in orbit to line
up and synchronize in orbit and then
make contact with each other is an
unbelievable feat like what was his name
butch that the pilot that was showing us
around in Houston oh yeah yeah he was to
Houston cuz he started telling me about
orbital mechanics of how like if one
spacecraft is like 10 feet higher in
orbit than another the lower one will
travel significantly faster so if you're
trying to meet the other spacecraft in
orbit and you're trying to like like I
think Neil even says it in a film thrust
to me sure that thing you're actually
going slower than you think you are it's
like the most counterintuitive crazy
physics that I've never heard of and I
was like that's impossible again that's
why we wouldn't make it yeah my last
thing for you guys I'm a huge fan of
Damian's work I can share a little bit
about what it was like collaborating
with them and maybe what surprised you
about working with them was younger than
me
that's the first time that's happened in
my career which was awesome but he's
he's really sharp like he's uh he's a
very affable guy you know he's he's fun
to get to know but he is so prepared and
so specific in his preparation like he
and Lina's this are cemet agra fur
and Ryan were were so synced up by the
time that we got to filming that it was
just like they were just executing the
plan it was like it was uh it flowed
very nicely and um you know he's a young
guy but I've sitting there I was like
I'm watching a master filmmaker right
now it's pretty incredible he's my
favorite filmmaker in a long time
honestly so as soon as I saw whiplash
I'm like what the hell is this this is
unbelie-- I couldn't believe it when I
saw that film I watched it seven times
or something I haven't done that in
years like 10 15 years so I'm a big big
fan of his and it was very cool to get
to be in a movie that he directed
especially with this as the subject
matter it was pretty special I got to
stop there seriously Congrats movies
[ __ ] awesome
[Music]
[Music]